prime minister Jacinda adern she is the
woman who you may remember the video at
the height of kovitz said do not believe
anything unless we tell it to you we the
government uh anyway here's a little
video of her she's a wef stooge here's a
little video of her past covid
authoritarianism and you'll you'll see
why we're showing you this in just a sec
do you think that emboldens the
protesters and do you think it's a
responsible thing to do no I don't think
it was a responsible thing to do for a
party that purports to be the champion
of Law and Order or indeed businesses to
meet with those who are obstructing
wellingtonians from going about their
everyday lives bullying and harassing
people who are trying to go to school or
work I trusted government and then I was
supposed to take this because I'm losing
my job if we weren't coerced and
brainwashed into getting these vaccines
he could still be alive
if we weren't forced into making a
choice between our jobs incomes and
livelihoods
he could still be alive if you want
summer
if you want to go to bars and
restaurants get vaccinated if you want
to get a haircut get vaccinated bullying
and harassing people if you want to go
to a concert or a festival get
vaccinated if you want to go to a gym or
a sports event get vaccinated
obstructing wellingtonians from going
about their everyday lives if you are
not vaccinated there will be everyday
things you will miss out on here she is
a short video talking about two classes
of citizens that they were going to have
in New Zealand
so you basically said this is going to
be like well it's almost like you
probably don't see it like this the two
different classes of people if you're
vaccinated or if you're unvaccided you
have all these rights if you are
vaccinated that is what it is so yep I'm
showing you this because this woman who
all of her actions are very much like
Justin Trudeau's right he was calling
all of the people who were against his
mandates all of the worst things in the
world she wanted in a place like New
Zealand people to be backs to be at
outdoor concerts and everything else
well something has happened people and
here's the good Twist on this thing she
announced her resignation last night
enough people are stepping up people are
not swallowing the nonsense anymore and
this this Joy Behar you think Kevin
McCarthy's soulless no no this soulless
woman who who abused her own citizens
abused her power she's now stepping down
and so today I'm announcing that I will
not be seeking re-election
and then my team as prime minister will
conclude no later than the 7th of
February see the pain on her face she
either knows that she sold her soul or
she knows she's done something evil or
she knows that people died on her watch
or something uh here's what the meme
makers of the internet did with that
clip
and so today I'm announcing that I will
not be seeking re-election
and then my tourist prime minister will
conclude no later than the 7th of
February getting rid of these people I
don't know exactly what's going on there
but she's gone Trudeau will be gone soon
enough there are real journalists like
Ezra Levant and Avi yemeni and people at
Rebel that are doing the work while the
corporate media fails us at every level
and it carries water and runs cover for
these people I will not stop I hope you
will not stop
[Music]
foreign
[Music]